wir kommen zum letzten
Tagesordnungspunkt an diesem Freitag es
wird noch eine Aktuelle Stunde jetzt
aufgerufen
von der afd-fraktion ist sie beantragt
unter anderem die Causa Patricia
Schlesinger ehemalige rbb-intendantin
ehemalige ARD-Vorsitzende hat eine
Diskussion über Leistungen Grenzen und
auch Kontrollen des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks
angestoßen die Diskussion wird hier auch
im Bundestag geführt
und die
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin katrin
Göring-Eckardt wird jetzt diese aktuelle
Stunde
Aufrufen der erste Redner kommt von der
antragstellenden Fraktion von der AFD
das wird sein Martin Erwin Renner
hochwertiges Präsidium meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren wir reden hier
über den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk
und den doch wirklich dringend
notwendigen Reformen Reform der
Finanzierung Reform zu
Qualitätssicherung Reform der
programmredundanz Reform der
wettbewerbslosen
Marktpositionierung beformt der
kontroll- und Aufsichtsstrukturen vieles
ist in den letzten Tagen und Wochen ans
Tageslicht gekommen die Zwangsgebühren
zahlen die Bürger sind entsetzt nein in
Wirklichkeit sind sie wütend ARD und ZDF
wirken wie gelähmt so als hätten sie
total den Boden unter den Füßen verloren
Gott sei Dank nehmen sie aber trotzdem
noch jeden Tag 23,1 Millionen Euro an
Zwangsgebühren ein täglich den Bürger
abgepresstes Geld egal ob er das Angebot
des Rundfunks nutzt oder dieses
ignoriert die Bürger sind mehrheitlich
der Meinung alles wäre besser als das
was wir jetzt haben wie die Made wie die
Made im Zwangsgebühren Speck frisst sich
dieser öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk
wettbewerbslos rund und Fett viele
Bürger erscheint heute der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk als ein
hochspendabler Arbeitgeber für die
höhere und häufig leistungslose
Führungskräfte oder auch als ein gut
gefüllte
Pensionskasse mit einem geschlossenem
Sendebetrieb
aus der ursprünglich fantastischen Idee
nach dem Krieg einen unabhängigen
informationsinstitution zu schaffen die
sich nicht im Wettbewerb mit anderen
Medien behaupten musst du und muss ist
eine einzige wahre Phase geworden die
Kriterien waren und sind Transport einer
waren Informationen und Meinungsvielfalt
neutrale Abbildung aller
gesellschaftlich relevanten Gruppen
sachlich aufbereitete
Informationsvermittlung das sind heute
in den Führungsetagen des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks keine
relevanten Kriterien mehr die neuen
Kriterien sind offenbar mein Dienstwagen
meine Chefetage und meine prunkbehausung
mein Massagesessel mein Gehalt meine
Pension meine Spesen wir alle wissen
wovon die Rede ist
es ist allerhöchste Zeit für Reformen
aber wir reden hier nicht nur über die
skandalösen finanziellen Ausschweifungen
und es reicht mit nichtem aus nur über
eine Deckelung der ebendanten Gehälter
und eine Reduzierung der Anzahl der
anwesenden Journalisten auf dem
CDU-Parteitag zu reden so wie der
beständig rechts blinkende und dann doch
links grün rot abbiegende Quoten März
medienwirksam vor einigen Tagen
verkündete die Probleme liegen sehr viel
tiefer das Totalversagen der aufsichts-
und Kontrollgremien deren Personal
zumeist aus dem politischen oder Politik
nahen Raum kommt und damit ist das
Wegschauen die Kumpanei die Verfilzung
in diesem zunehmend wirkenden
politmedialen Konstrukt doch schon
ziemlich hinreichend erklärt da wird aus
dem Herrn Ministerpräsidenten Günther
schon mal der Liebe Daniel
da wird dem lieben Daniel mal ganz
schnell ein chefredaktioneller
Schutzschirm aufgespannt wenn er im
Regen steht und er nass zu werden droht
diese öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk ist
so nicht mehr zeitgemäß
diese Rundfunk ist nicht mehr die
fertige Gewalt und damit der
Trollen der politischen Macht im
Gegenteil er hat sich zum Herold und zum
stichwortlieferanten der politisch
Mächtigen gewandelt die Zwangsgebühren
müssen abgeschafft werden niemand darf
gezwungen werden für green linke
bevormundungs- und
induktionsanstalten zu zahlen
bei ARD und ZDF gibt es nur noch einen
Aufwärtstrend nämlich das
Durchschnittsalter der Zuschauer und
immer mehr Mahnverfahren beim
beitragsservice
84 Prozent der Bürger sind nicht mehr
Willens Zwangsgebühren zu zahlen ich
streiche das Zwangsgebühr eigentlich
heißt es ja und soll heißen
demokratieabgabe aber auch die
zunehmende Durchdringung des Rundfunks
im Internet muss begrenzt werden wenn
die gewaltige Finanzmacht der
öffentlich-rechtlichen die anderen
Medien dort dominiert und auf mittlere
Sicht wird das soweit kommen dann droht
die endgültige publizistische
Verwahrlosung aus Meinungsvielfalt wird
dann eine sehr schnell eine sehr
gleichgeschaltete meinungseinfalt wer
jetzt
nur die spitzengelder Deckeln möchte
offenbart seine Ahnungslosigkeit oder
seine
opportunistische Bereitschaft zur
Kameraderie gerade die digitale
Revolution und das ist die Zukunft der
Medien im Internet wirkt viele und auch
höchst komplexe Fragen auf und um diese
Fragen zu klären auch unter einem Bezug
von
expertie von Experten um diese Fragen zu
klären werden wir in den nächsten Tagen
sehr sehr vernünftige Vorschläge machen
danke schön
[Applaus]
für die SPD-Fraktion hat Helge Lindt das
Wort
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen wenn jemand wie die Made im
Speck lebt dann die AFD im spektr der
Demokratie es ist die Zusammenfassung
ihrer Existenz
angesichts aber dieser ernsthaften Krise
sind aus unserer Sicht zwei Dinge
notwendig nämlich Flucht nach vorne und
auch Flucht und das schonungslos in die
Wahrheit und das Instrument dafür ist
Demokratisierung und dessen Werkzeuge
sind harte
konsequente und einheitliche Standards
von Compliance Governance Integrität
Transparenz was passiert mit
Whistleblower Mechanismen sind sie
wirklich unabhängig wie funktioniert die
Aufsicht was ist mit Gehaltsstrukturen
was für Verträge werden vergeben wie
sieht es aus mit Verträgen für
Produktionsgesellschaften was für Betrag
Berater sind eingebunden und vieles
weiter sind Gremien wirklich in der Lage
ermächtigt zu werden sind wenn sie
juristisch gut beraten und unabhängig
all das sind zentrale Fragen einer
solchen Demokratisierung
Demokratisierung ist aber auch aus
unserer Sicht die Situation der
Mitarbeitenden
nämlich sie sind doppelt verraten
einerseits durch Stimmungsmache gegen
den öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk und
andererseits gerade durch die Führung
ihrer Häuser und deshalb stehen wir an
der Seite der Mitarbeitenden und ist die
Antwort unter anderem Mitbestimmung für
die festen aber auch für die freien und
für die festen Freien und auch genau
ihre Beteiligung an dem Struktur und
Reformprozess Demokratisierung ist aber
noch mehr
Demokratisierung ist auch entschiedener
Mut zum Dialog mit der Bevölkerung
gerade jetzt in der Krise gerade in
diesem Moment das heißt übrigens nicht
Dialog mit der Bevölkerung den
Anweisungen von Herrn Merz zu folgen und
Herr Merz ist auch nicht auch wenn es
manchmal denkt die Bevölkerung und da
komme ich zu einem wichtigen Punkt in
dem Zusammenhang aus meiner Sicht ein
unerhörter Punkt auf dem Bundesparteitag
der CDU hat Herr Merz in eindeutig
hämischen
latendronenden sehr spitzen Ton geredet
von der stolzen Zahl von 58
Redakteurinnen und Redakteurin des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks mit
denen man sich besonders liebenswürdig
beschäftigt würde ich finde das
gegenüber einer Berichterstattung
absolut inakzeptabel übergriffig
unanständig so zu reden es wirkt aber
diese perfide Strategie wirkt in zwei
Intendanten fühlten sich nahezu
gezwungen im Nachhinein Rechtfertigung
zu äußern ich fand diese Rechtfertigung
nicht nötig und ehrlich gesagt falsch
aber der Druck war so groß es geht aber
noch weiter
das große Thema das Herr Merz als
Parteivorsitzender Fraktionsvorsitzender
entdeckt hat ist auch die
Unausgewogenheit und er benutzt dafür
eine in rechtspopulistischen Kreisen
sehr beliebte nichtstudie der zufolge
angeblich 90 Prozent der Volontärinnen
grün Links oder SPD orientiert werden
jetzt haben wir folgendes Problem damit
was sagt uns das es ist überhaupt keine
wissenschaftliche Aussage zum zweiten
wollen wir eine Gewissensprüfung machen
fangen wir jetzt an bei Lehrerinnen
Lehrern zu fragen nach der
parteiorientierung oder bei den
mitarbeiten des BMI drittens bestimmen
die Volontäre innen über das Programm
des öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks und
viertens und das ist ein ganz
interessante Frage diese Volontärin
kommen aus der Altersgruppe 18 bis 24 in
dieser Altersgruppe haben die
traditionellen Volksparteien ziemlich
schlechte Ergebnisse und die CDU
besonders schlechtergebnisse mit zehn
Prozent es ist doch nicht das Problem
des öffentlichen heftigen Rundfunks wenn
zu wenige Leute die CDU wählen sondern
es ist ihr Problem und das Problem von
Herrn märz und
kommen wir zum dritten Thema in dieser
Debatte das angesprochen werden muss
Geschlechter gerechte Sprache Gendern in
einer Talkshow sprach Herr Merz vom Rat
der deutschen Sprache und regelmäßig
spricht davon dass man sich beim
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk zu
halten habe an die allgemeinen
anerkannten Regeln der deutschen Sprache
erstens ein Rat der deutschen Sprache
gibt es nicht zweitens
Rechtschreibung ist nicht Sprache und
man kann Humboldt lesen auch
ludwig-wittgenstein Sprache ist
dynamisch Sprache ist im Wandel sie wird
weder von einem Rat noch von uns noch
von einer Partei noch von Herrn Merz
verordnet drittens heißt es ja ich
zitiere die deutsche Sprache und die
Sprache von
Goethe und Schiller Kant und hege die
deutsche Sprache heute ist aber auch die
Sprache von selfie özdema und sei molu
ist die Sprache von donatilla die Cesare
und David kamani und deshalb frage ich
mich Herr Merz auch in Abwesenheit
ernsthaft in welchem Museum leben sie in
keinem Museum weder städtisch noch
ländlich gibt es diese Gesellschaft in
der sie leben deshalb erklären Sie mir
bitte ein anderer Stelle wo der
Zusammenhang besteht zwischen zwischen
Korruption und Fragen der fehlenden
Compliance im öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunk und der Lösung durch die
Genderfrage wenn zeigen vielen Dank
ansonsten hinterlassen Sie diese
Erpressungsversuche und stehen wir
gemeinsam gerade in der Situation zum
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk
[Applaus]
hägelin war das für die SPD-Fraktion
jetzt hören wir als nächsten Redner in
dieser aktuellen Stunde
Maximilian Merseburg für die CDU
CSU-Fraktion
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen am
Freitagnachmittag
Liebe afd-fraktion die um diese aktuelle
Stunde gebeten hat und für die ich
natürlich gerne die erste Eröffnung des
Cannstatter wasens das kann statt der
Volksfest als Wahlkreisabgeordnete heute
verpasst vielen Dank dafür aber es ist
in der Tat gut dass wir uns heute im
Bundestag mit diesem Thema ganz zum
Schluss noch
auseinandersetzen wenn ich zum Beispiel
bei Herrn freser lese aus der
afd-fraktion der in einer
Pressemitteilung schreibt solche
Propaganda verdient kein Cent
zwangsbeitrag Herr Renner sie haben
diese Worte ja auch gerade schon wieder
gewählt weil irgendeine Grafik
jedenfalls ihrer Meinung nach verzehrt
war dann wird mal wieder klar mit ihnen
kann man über keinen politisches Thema
sprechen ohne dass sie die verbale
Besucher auspacken
Propaganda meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren die systematische Verbreitung
politische Ideen mit dem Ziel des
allgemeinen Bewusstsein in eine
bestimmte Richtung zu lenken
was als nächstes kommt es können Sie das
werden sie schon denken auf ihre Partei
trifft es ganz besonders zu nur sie
bauen einen eigenen TV-Kanal auf nur sie
wollen ein afd-studio in Berlin Gründen
das steht auf Ihre Homepage und wenn
Frau Weidel dann davon spricht dass sie
einen grundfunk mit neutrale
Berichterstattung möchte dann wissen wir
doch was das ist nämlich ein Sender in
dem sie entscheiden was neutral ist und
nicht der unabhängige Journalist
doch nur weil die einen nicht wissen wie
man Probleme adressiert ohne sich dabei
wie ein Elefant im Porzellanladen zu
benehmen heißt es nicht dass nicht wir
anderen trotzdem darüber sprechen müssen
Herr Lindt ich glaube sie haben das
jetzt gerade ausgeführt ich fand es
bisschen komisch das ist schon ein
Problem ist wenn die Volontäre aus nur
eine Milieu rekrutiert werden ich glaube
dass es schon Probleme gibt die
ungeheuerlichen Ereignisse beim rbb
müssen angesprochen werden auch die
Entwicklung des Programms und auch die
Kosten sind natürlich ein Auftrag
deswegen haben wir uns als CDU in der
Tat im Bundesparteitag mit diesem Thema
auseinandergesetzt und wir haben einige
Punkte zusammengefasst erstens wir
müssen notwendige Reformen auf den Weg
bringen weil die Struktur des
intransparent ist und unzureichend
kontrolliert wird Wolfgang Güttner ihr
Parteikollege Herr Lindt ist seit zehn
Jahren Mitglied im Rundfunkrat des NDR
und sagt der Rundfunkrat beschließt ein
Etat über rund eine Milliarde Euro erst
der Meinung dass nicht alle Mitglieder
gründlich diesen Haushalt durchdrungen
haben das ist richtig und deswegen
brauchen wir ein reformiertes
Kontrollsystem das sowohl neutral als
auch wirkmächtig ist wir wollen das ist
auch eine stärker Repräsentanz von
Beitragszahlern in den Aufsichtsrat in
den Aufsichtsgremien gibt und das
betriebswirtschaftliche Expertise
einfließen kann zum Beispiel durch
Wirtschaftsprüfer das ist nicht alles
zweitens so oft sieht man politische
Unterhaltungsformate in denen Sprache
und Aussage der beteiligten sich kaum
unterscheidet zurück zu den Problemen
mit dem sie sich auseinandergesetzt
haben Herrn aber das sie leider nicht
erkannt haben wir können diesen
Verantwortlichen nur raten dass sie sich
einsetzen vervielfalt aber Vielfalt eben
nicht nur in Herkunft und Geschlecht
sondern auch in den Meinungen denn das
ist das worauf es ankommt auch in den
Ausdrucksweisen und in den Meinungen ist
übrigens anders als dies gesagt haben
sie sagen März spricht nicht für das
Volk für 86 Prozent spricht er eben doch
in der Frage der Gender Sprache das sagt
selbst der MDR selbst
zur ausgewogenen Bericht der Stadt und
gehört es auch dass es eine gute
Trennung zwischen Kommentar auf der
einen Seite Berichterstattung auf der
anderen Seite gibt wir müssen vor allem
darauf achten beim Online-Formular dass
ich an jüngere richtet dort muss es
deutlich kontrolliert werden wir wollen
unabhängige Studien und Befragungen die
das prüfen und zuletzt natürlich auch
die Kosten diese Beiträge sind einfach
nicht mehr vermittelbar und dürfen nicht
weiter steigen wir schlagen vor dass wir
eine Veröffentlichungspflicht einführen
für die Gehälter und die Nebeneinkünfte
der Leitungspositionen und dass sich
diese an den öffentlichen Einrichtungen
orientieren und nicht an den privaten
Medien klar das gefällt nicht jedem und
wenn wir uns und andere mit diesen
Themen auseinandersetzen dann ist es
nicht Populismus wie ein
ard-chefredakteur den Kollegen von der
FDP zuletzt vorgeworfen hat es heißt
dass wir eben doch das Vertrauen Schaden
genommen hat dass wir in den ÖAR
eigentlich hatten
deswegen reden wir über Themen auch über
das Thema der presseähnlichkeit weil
natürlich müssen wir darauf achten dass
die privaten Qualitätsmedien in Zukunft
nicht vom ÖAR vom Online-Markt verdrängt
werden weil sie exakt die gleichen
Angebote im Petto haben die CDU setzt zu
diesem Themen des öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunks eine Kommission ein und diese
Reformbereitschaft erwarten wir von
allen insbesondere von den
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunkanstalten
selbst vielen Dank
Maximilian mörseburg war das für die
cdu/csu-fraktion ihm folgt jetzt ihr hat
Grundl für die Bündnisgrünen der
Sprecher für Kultur-
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine
Damen und Herren wenn wir über den
öffentlich-rechtlichen reden müssen wir
uns klar werden was wir wollen und was
wir nicht wollen
wir wollen in Deutschland eine
Informationslandschaft oder wollen wir
die die dominiert ist von einer
Berichterstattung aller Fox News wollen
wir eine Medienlandschaft in der nur die
skandalisierendste Schlagzeile und die
Produktion vorkommt die die höchste
Einschaltquote bringt ich sage Ihnen das
wollen wir nicht und das werden wir auch
nicht zulassen
die tragende Säule unserer freien
Demokratie ist eine vielfältige
Medienlandschaft in der sowohl privat
finanzierten Journalismus den
gemeinnützigen Journalismus und
öffentlich-rechtlichen Journalismus gibt
der Qualitätsjournalismus des
öffentlich-rechtlichen der von
journalist:innen in unabhängigen
Redaktionen erarbeitet wird das ist das
Fundament und dieses Fundament wird im
Zeitalter der Fake News noch viel viel
wichtiger werden der ÖAR in Deutschland
wurde nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg und
nach den Gräueltaten der deutschen
Nationalsozialisten gegründet es sollte
nie wieder einen zentralen staatlich
gesteuerten propaganda-sender geben und
genau das wurde umgesetzt indem es
vielfältige selbstverwaltete föderal
organisierte Sender gibt die durch
Gebühren finanziert werden der
grundsätzliche Auftrag des
öffentlich-rechtlichen wird von den
Ländern im medienstaatsvertrag
festgelegt
und die Sender des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks und da
stehen nicht der Kontrolle der Politik
die Journalistin steht nicht ihrer
brötchengeberin gegenüber wenn sie im
Interview kritische Fragen stellt denn
der öffentlich-rechtliche ist wie ich
sagte beitragsfinanziert und das ist
seine Stärke er ist unabhängig von
regierungsmehrheiten er ist unabhängig
von Überlegungen eines
Haushaltsausschusses im Bundestag oder
eines Finanzministers und das ist auch
gut so es steht außer Frage das
Vetternwirtschaft oder gar Einflussnahme
auf die Berichterstattung nicht sein
dürfen darum erwarten wir klare Reformen
in den Sendern strikte Compliance
Regelungen Regelungen in denen
Vergabeverfahren und amtsausstattung
geregelt sind weitreichende
Finanzentscheidungen müssen durch
Gremien getroffen werden es braucht
transparente und nachvollziehbare
Gehaltsstrukturen für Führungspositionen
es müssen die Kontrollgremien gestärkt
werden die ehrenamtlichen Mitglieder der
Geräte müssen gut ausgestattet sein sie
brauchen zuarbeitende unabhängige
gremienbüros und medienpolitische
Schulungen und die Arbeit der
Redaktionen muss gestärkt werden diese
Arbeit ist als Rückgrat für die
Akzeptanz des öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunks in der Bevölkerung ich möchte
nicht die Räterepublik in den
Redaktionen ausrufen aber was spricht
eigentlich gegen rotierende
Chefredaktionen was wir ablehnen ist die
sogenannte Rückbesinnung auf eine
journalistische Grundversorgung wer den
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk nur für
diese Grundversorgung lobt er spricht
ein vergiftetes Lob aus das Streichen
von Unterhaltung aus dem Programmauftrag
bedeutet eine eklatante Schwächung des
öffentlich-rechtlichen dem stellen wir
uns entschieden entgegen
ja wir brauchen tiefgreifende Recherche
und die aufwendige Doku aber ja wir
wollen auch Unterhaltung den gemeinsam
erlebte Unterhaltung Bauten 10 Millionen
ZuschauerInnen bleiben nach dem Tatort
dran um noch Anne Will zu schauen da
kommen übrigens auch sie vor
der Zusammenspiel von Unterhaltung und
Informationsangeboten das ist attraktiv
wer also die Unterhaltung aus dem
Programmauftrag streichen möchte der
möchte in der Konsequenz
öffentlich-rechtliche
Informationsangebote in unserer
vielfältigen Medienlandschaft
zurückdrängen und das werden wir nicht
zulassen wir brauchen den
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk
dringender denn jeden wir dürfen die
deutsche Medienlandschaft nicht
federführend den krakehler:innen und
nicht den profitgeiern überlassen
zum Schluss verehrte Kolleginnen der CDU
und der CSU es wundert mich immer wieder
dass nirgends so aufgeregt und viel über
das Gendern gesprochen wird wie in ihrem
Zirkeln der Parteivorsitzende März
schreibt dazu eifrig Gastbeiträge und
auch bei ihrem Parteitag in Hannover
musste das Gendern als zentrales und
raumgreifendes
Eingangsthema herhalten ganz besonders
das Gendern im öffentlich-rechtlichen
man fragt sich ist das ihr Topthema
wollen sie allen Ernstes unabhängigen
JournalistInnen vorschreiben wie sie zu
sprechen haben wenn es nicht so traurig
wäre dann könnte man lachen dass die
wahren gender Nerds dieses Landes hier
vereint auf der rechten Seite dieses
Hauses sitzen
[Applaus]
Skater live wie man in Niederbayern sagt
legen sie ihre sprachpolizistinnen
Uniformen zurück in den Wandschrank der
Geschichte und lassen sie die deutsche
Sprache in
Ruhe
und wenn Sie das Gendern so anfischt
wenn Sie das Gendern so anfiegt dann
gibt es eine ganz einfache Empfehlung
verwenden Sie die nächsten 2000 Jahre
die weibliche Form und fühlen sich
mitgedacht vielen Dank
er hat Grundel war das für die Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen es folgt jetzt in
dieser aktuellen Stunde für die
Linksfraktion Petra Sitte die Sprecherin
für Medienpolitik
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
ich will eine Vorbemerkung machen und
kann da sehr gut an Herrn Grundel
anschließen wir sollten uns in dieser
Debatte schon über die Dimension
aktueller Diskussionen klar werden
insbesondere mit Blick auf die
Geschichte des öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunks er wurde nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg insbesondere nach dem Vorbild
der britischen BBC als Antwort auf
Gleichstellung aller Medien zu Zeiten
des Faschismus also als Antwort auf
göppels Propagandamaschinerie gegründet
und entwickelt
seitdem trägt er einen öffentlichen
Auftrag ein inhaltlich wie finanziell
unabhängiges vielfältiges Medienangebot
zu schaffen es ist also nicht irgendeine
Wahl die man da treffen kann Vielfalt
ist Auftrag nicht als schönes Beiwerk
sondern als mit Garant für demokratische
Ordnung in diesem Auftrag erwächst eine
große Verantwortung die immer wieder
eingefordert werden muss und ich sage
Ihnen schon die aktuellen Ereignisse
lassen einen da manchmal verzweifeln da
gibt es selbstherrige in den intendanzen
da meinen der welche es ist hier ein
Selbstbedienungsladen oder es Versagen
eben tragischerweise auch
Kontrollstrukturen das ist nicht nur ein
Schlag ins Gesicht der
gebührenzahlerinnen und Zahler sondern
auch der eigenen Mitarbeitenden da haben
sie völlig recht Herr lind deren oft
unter prekären Bedingungen geleistete
gute Arbeit Gerät nämlich in Mithaftung
und in miss und das dürfen wir nicht
zulassen
gleichwohl gilt es auch folgendes
festzuhalten dass die Aufklärung über
solche Vorgänge auch in den betroffenen
öffentlich-rechtlichen Medien selbst
stattfindet halte ich jedenfalls für
bemerkenswert und ich kann mir den
Vorgang schwer in privaten Medien
vorstellen meine Damen und Herren die
Beschäftigten freie und feste freie
müssen jetzt bei allen anstehenden
Entscheidungen unbedingt gehört werden
sie müssen mitentscheiden können und Sie
verdienen gleichzeitig unsere
Unterstützung im Kampf um bessere
Arbeitsbedingungen
nicht genug das Journalistinnen und
Journalisten offen während ihrer Arbeit
auf Demonstrationen beispielsweise
behindert bedroht oder körperlich direkt
angegriffen werden nein jetzt wird einem
populistischen Impuls folgend auch noch
Berichterstattung verächtlich gemacht
meine Damen und Herren von der CDU ihr
letzter Parteitag war ein Beleg dafür
wie man genau nicht mit diesen Fragen
umgehen können und sollte was geschehen
ist beim NDR beispielsweise ist noch ein
viel schwieriges Problem weil das
nämlich das glaubt die Glaubwürdigkeit
die Vertrauenswürdigkeit des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks in
Frage stellt und deshalb müssen wir auch
dagegen ankämpfen
und ich finde eben dass es sich Politik
bisweilen zu einfach macht wir tragen
nämlich auch konkrete Mitverantwortung
vielleicht mal so ein historischen aus
dem Befreiungskriegen ich war 14 Jahre
Fraktionsvorsitzende in Sachsen-Anhalt
und als ich aufgehört habe haben mir MDR
Kollegen gesagt wissen Sie Frau Sitte
sie haben in den ganzen Jahren zwei Mal
angerufen das haben wir uns gemerkt weil
es halt so selten war aber es gibt
Kollegen in ihrem Landtag die rufen
zweimal wöchentlich an und das ist ja
nicht versehentlich sondern das hat
natürlich konkrete Absicht Einfluss zu
nehmen und deshalb muss man das dringend
verändern und zwar nicht erst wenn ein
Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts in
Karlsruhe gefällt wird
und schließlich nicht ohne Grund hat die
antidemokratische Rechte weltweit den
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk als
Feindbild identifiziert wer mit diesen
Wölfen heult trägt nicht zu Lösungen bei
sondern zur Auflösung und das wollen sie
und das wissen sie natürlich die
Versuche in Großbritannien und in
Frankreich oder eben auch in anderen
Ländern den öffentlichen Rundfunk
gefügig zu machen sollte uns sollten uns
tatsächlich ein warnendes Beispiel sein
aber genauso fatal wäre es jetzt in eine
Wagenburgmentalität zu verfallen die
Politik muss zu diesen Reform mit
Treiber sein sie muss aber die
Unabhängigkeit sie muss die unabhängige
Aufsicht des öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunks tatsächlich stärken und wie
gesagt nicht auf Gerichtsprozesse bzw
Urteile warten für diese nötige
Entwicklung braucht es ein
gesellschaftlichen Dialog das sehe ich
genauso Herr Lindt und es braucht mehr
Teilhabe und Mitbestimmung ein starker
öffentlich-rechtlicher Rundfunk muss ich
darauf besinnen was von ihm im
Unterschied zu privatwirtschaftlichen
Medien erwartet wird und zwar nicht nur
im Angebot sondern im in der gesamten
Arbeitsweise Abschluss wenn die
Öffentlich-Rechtlichen sagt der eine
oder andere bisweilen wenn es sie nicht
gäbe müsste man sie erfinden meine
Lieblingsprogramme sind 3Sat und Arte
aber treffender wäre doch wohl zu sagen
wenn wir wollen letzter Satz wenn wir
wollen dass es sie weitergibt müssen wir
sie neu erfinden ich danke
hat für die FDP-Fraktion das Wort
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich weiß nicht
wie es Ihnen geht so am Ende der
Sitzungswoche nachdem wir viel
deportiert debattiert viel diskutiert
haben
achten wir mit bisschen Spannung auf die
letzten Tagesordnungspunkt die Aktuelle
Stunde bevor wir alle zurück in unsere
Wahlkreise dürfen zurück in unsere
Heimat viel haben ihren Woche diskutiert
Krieg in der Ukraine das Leid der
Menschen dort die Auswirkungen auf unser
Land Inflation und Energiesicherheit und
zum Abschluss nun der öffentliche
Rundfunk Länderhoheit und in der
Aktuellen Stunde
auf Antrag der AFD nach fünf Minuten
Impuls von Herrn Renner haben wir gehört
ja wir brauchen eine Aktuelle Stunde
damit wir hier die AFD in den nächsten
Wochen Ihnen Vorschläge zur Reform des
öffentlichen Rundfunks vorlegen werden
dann hätten wir doch vielleicht erst
nachgedacht und die Vorschläge
präsentiert und dann in der Aktuellen
Stunde diskutiert dann könnten wir uns
über die Vorschläge auch
auseinandersetzen so diskutieren wir im
luftleeren Raum was ihre Gedanken angeht
wir haben konkrete Vorstellungen wie es
mit dem öffentlichen grundfunk
weitergehen soll dabei ist ja das Ziel
der AFD über die Zukunft des
öffentlichen Rundfunks klar und ich bin
sicher Herr jungen wird es gleich
dezidierter und vielleicht auch etwas
prägnanter noch da bieten ihnen geht es
um die Zerstörung des öffentlichen
Rundfunks um die Zerstörung der
Glaubwürdigkeit aber auch in die
Zerstörung der Strukturen und da kann
ich Ihnen sagen für uns ist der
öffentliche Rundfunk teil unserer
grundgesetzlich garantierten
Medienvielfalt Meinungsfreiheit und
damit ein Grundsatz der nicht verändert
werden kann in unserem Grundgesetz im
Zuge unserer Konstitution öffentlicher
Rundfunk gemeinsam mit den freien Wegen
gehen sind der Garant der
Meinungsvielfalt und darf mit
unerlässlich
aber warum will denn die AFD den
öffentlichen Rundfunk zerstören weil
dort Fakten präsentiert werden weil der
Informationen gegeben werden weil der
öffentliche Rundfunk bei der im Großteil
weil der öffentliche Rundfunk bei dem
Großteil der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
Glaubwürdigkeit besitzt die Tagesschau
heute
Nachrichtensendungen aber auch das
Auftreten im
in den sozialen Medien in der digitalen
Welt alles das ist das Gegenteil von dem
was sie produzieren durch ihre
fraktionsmeinungen durch ihre
Präsentationen im Internet und solange
sie sich Frau von Storch in ihrer Bubble
bewegen und dort ihre Sicht auf das was
hier passiert im Parlament aber auch in
diesem Land präsentieren ist dass das
eine wenn aber andere die große Mehrheit
in diesem Hause und die Medien draußen
und der öffentliche Rundfunk dagegen die
Wahrheit setzt dann machte sie stören es
ist aber wichtig für die Informationen
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger draußen und
diese Glaubwürdigkeit
und diese glaubwürdigkeit ist der Erfolg
vieler engagierter Journalistinnen und
Journalisten die sich einsetzen jenseits
von Verfehlungen auf der Intendanten
Ebene oder in der Verwaltung ihrer
Häuser und wenn wir auch mit der
Deutschen Welle die auch Teil des
öffentlichen Rundfunks ist Informationen
in andere Länder geben darüber was
in Russland passiert wie der
Kriegsverlauf in der Ukraine ist dann
mag das sie stören für uns ist es aber
wichtig gehört dazu zur Wahrheit auch in
der Welt aber
meine Damen und Herren der Reformbedarf
beim öffentlichen Rundfunk ist vorhanden
man kann ihn nicht leugnen in vielen in
Deutschland ist der öffentliche Rundfunk
zu aufgebläht zu schwerfällig zu
selbstverliebt gar keinen Strukturen
sind offensichtlich missbrauchsanfällig
und veraltet Spitzengehälter Dienstwegen
werden diskutiert Intendantinnen und
andere Fälle nicht nur beim rbb in
Hamburg Kiel München oder Sachsen-Anhalt
zeigen mangelnde Kostenkontrolle und
Compliance Fehler erste Reformen auch
das muss man konzentrieren sind auf dem
Weg gebracht der Rundfunk der
medienänderung Staatsvertrag hat den
rundfunkauftrag neu definiert und das
ist doch das wo man anfangen müssen
Informationen Bildung Kultur und dann
danebensatz abgesetzt dann erst die
Unterhaltung Veränderungen im Programm
werden wir erwarten werden wir
beobachten und werden wir auch
einfordern
muss folgen Aufsicht zum Strukturen
müssen erneuert werden was macht der
Verwaltungsrat was macht der Rundfunkrat
welche
qualifikationsvoraussungen sind
vorsetzungen für die Räte sind den
notwendig reicht es auch engagiert zu
sein in einer gesellschaftlichen
engagation
oder muss es nicht auch Kompetenz und
Qualifikation geben wir wollen den
Rundfunk fit machen für die Zukunft dazu
müssen Bund und Länder gemeinsam
arbeiten Impulse der Gesellschaft
aufnehmen und weiterentwickeln wir
wollen aufgrund der komplizierten
strukturellen Verfasser verfassheit des
öffentlichen Rundfunks die Länder ja
besonders in die Pflicht nehmen in der
Pflicht Länder Ego ist man hinter sich
lassen und die Reform des öffentlichen
Rundfunks voranzubringen und darüber
sollen wir an diesem Wochenende
diskutieren nicht nur an diesem
Wochenende und nicht nur am Oktoberfest
oder in Cannstatter Wasen
vielen Dank
Thomas Hacker war das für die
FDP-Fraktion der medienpolitische
Sprecher jetzt
hören wir für die afd-fraktion
[Musik]
die nächsten
rednermarkierungen wird das sein der
kulturpolitische Sprecher der
afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
damit sich an Missständen in Deutschland
etwas ändert muss es offenbar zuerst
ganz schlimm kommen vorher werden
Kritiker ignoriert oder lächerlich
gemacht es brauchte erst die
haarsträubenden Skandale in der ARD bis
die Staatsmedien in ihrer ganzen
Verschwendungssucht Dysfunktionalität
und beteiligkeit jetzt auf den Prüfstand
kamen es wurde höchste Zeit
was Frau Schlesinger die mittlerweile
entlassene Intendantin des rbb sich eine
Luxuskarosse mit Massagesessel könnte
dass sie private Abendessen offenbar
dienstlich abgerechnet hat bei einem
Jahresgehalt von 303.000 Euro plus
Zulagen das ist nur das sichtbarste Teil
des Sumpfes das System Schlesinger ist
überall die ARD ist tief in ihre
Strukturen korrumpiert materiell und vor
allem geistig meine Damen und Herren
übrigens
WDR
hält 411.000 Euro Jahresgehalt plus über
300.000 Euro pensionsrücklagen das ist
mehr als der US-Präsident dabei heißt
der Herr noch nicht einmal wirklich Tom
sondern Thomas alles finanziert vom Geld
der zwangsgebührenzahler mit 8,4
Milliarden Euro füttern diese jährlich
den unersättlichen medienmoloch und wehe
ein Bürger widersetzt sich weil er das
Angebot vielleicht gar nicht nutzen will
dann droht Erzwingungshaft so 181 Tage
lang vollstreckt an Georg Thiel der dem
WDR 600 Euro schuldete Werte
Regierungsparteien im Bund und auch in
den Ländern was Präsident macron in
Frankreich geschafft hat ihr großes
Vorbild das müsst ihnen doch auch
möglich sein Schaffen sie endlich diese
Zwangsgebühren ab die sind auch keine
demokratieabgabe wie wdr-chefredakteur
Schönenborn falschen neue sprech sagte
sondern mittlerweile ja eine
propaganda-gebühr ich will jetzt gar
nicht auf dem vorbei der Tagesschau
herumreiten wir allen Ernstes meldete
ein Tüftler aus Simbabwe in Wahrheit ein
notorischer Betrüger habe einen
energieerzeugenden Fernseher erfunden so
viel zu faktenchecker Kompetenz unserer
Staatsmedien Herr Acker viel
gravierender ist aber der politische
Filz in den Aufsichtsgremien der ARD der
diese längst in einen
verlautbarungsorgan der regierenden
verwandelt hat schon in den 80er Jahren
sagte Franz Josef Strauß über den
Unterschied zwischen ARD und ZDF das ist
der gleiche Unterschied wie zwischen
Prater und ist westia heute bleibt einem
bei diesem Witz das Lachen im Halse
stecken wenn man zum Beispiel sieht
welch peinliche Lobeshymne eine
tagesthemen-moderatorin auf
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck kürzlich
gehalten hat warum ist er so beliebt ein
neuer politikertyp ein Macher das war
schon nahe an Nordkorea und kein Wunder
von den Volontären bei ARD und ZDF W 57
Prozent die Grünen 23 Prozent die
Linkspartei 12%, die SPD CDU und CSU
landen bei drei Prozent und die FDP bei
einem Prozent Werte CDU und FDP für ein
paar Chefsessel haben sie diesen
Linksruck in Deutschland zugelassen und
ihre politische Seele verkauft sie
sollten darüber mal nachdenken die AFD
wird natürlich konsequent draußen
gehalten wie er auch aus den Talkshows
Herr Merseburg wenn Ihnen das passierte
würden sie vielleicht auch an CDU TV
Gründen kommt ja vielleicht noch obwohl
wir wir dort für die demokratische
Vielfalt sorgen würden die sehr
angeblich so lieben und wenn einmal ein
afd-vertreter dort sitzt dann fällt das
politmediale Kartell Kollektiv über ihn
her damit er auch ganz bestimmt kein
Argument zu Ende führen kann Erziehung
und Bevormundung des Publikums das
verstehen unsere haltungsjournalisten
als ihre Hauptaufgabe und so werden den
Publikum eben nur schöne Bilder von
Flüchtlingen gezeigt hässliche Realität
wird ausgeblendet die Oma wird als
umweltsaudenuniziert wenn es der
vermeintlich guten Sache dient Winnetou
Filme werden nicht mehr gezeigt weil das
Denken des tumbenvolkes
endkolonialisiert werden muss im Kunde
und Jugendprogramm gibt es stattdessen
geschmacklose frühsexualisierung
vorzugsweise queer und natürlich wird
die gendersprache mit ihren
stolperpausen
ideologinnen sprachpolizist innen Herr
Bundes sie haben das sogar selbst gesagt
den Zusehern aufgedrängt ob sie es
wollen oder nicht und sie wollen es eben
vor allem nicht Herr Hacker über 40
Prozent der Deutschen haben nach einer
Umfrage kein Vertrauen in den
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk mehr das
ist ein Alarmsignal unser Mediensystem
hat sich überlebt es stammt aus einer
völlig anderen Zeit ohne in Internet mit
knappen Sendefrequenzen und muss
grundsätzlich reformiert werden das kann
nicht sein dass es seine Privilegien
jetzt auch noch auf das Internet
aussehen wie es zu geschehen droht ich
komme zum Schluss
nein in einer komplett Kommission des
Deutschen Bundestages dieser Reform zu
diskutieren und vorzubereiten unter
Antrag dazu federführenden Kollege
Renner geht ihnen Ausschuss verweigern
sie sich dieser Debatte bitte nicht und
bitte nicht mit so billigen Argumenten
wie wir sie heute gehört haben vielen
Dank
in unserer aktuellen Stunde folgen jetzt
noch sieben redner:innen und die nächste
Rednerin ist die Kollegin Simona Kos für
die SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren
Lehrerin aus ard-skandalen ziehen
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk jetzt
grundsätzlich reformieren so der
einigermaßen konstruktive Titel der
heutigen Aktuellen Stunde
einigermaßen deswegen weil sich die
Vorfälle über die wir reden nicht bei
der gesamten ARD ereignet haben sondern
allein bei zwei senderanstalten und zwar
dem Rundfunk Berlin-Brandenburg und dem
Norddeutschen Rundfunk auf die anderen 7
ARD-Anstalten von Radio Bremen über den
Hessischen Rundfunk bis hin zum
Südwestrundfunk beziehen sich diese
Vorwürfe nicht und schaut man genauer
hin dann haben wir es in beiden Fällen
mit führungsproblemen zu tun
beim rbb stehen erhebliche
compliance-stöße im Raum beim NDR geht
es darum dass eine Redaktionsleitung ihr
unbequeme Berichterstattung unterbunden
hat ich will sehr sehr vorsichtig sein
denn noch laufen die zum Teil
staatsanwaltlichen und zum Teil
senderintern Untersuchung aber das was
im Raume steht hat mit dem Kopf der
Anstalten nicht aber mit dem Körper zu
tun es ist ich wiederhole mich ein
Führungsproblem die Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter sowohl beim rbb wie beim NDR
fühlen sich bei ihrer Ehre gepackt und
Rollen seit Beginn der Vorwürfe die
Fakten auf
ich bin sehr beeindruckt in welcher
Tiefe und mit welchem Nachdruck die
Journalistinnen und Journalisten jetzt
die Missstände recherchieren Sie
ansprechen und aufarbeiten diese
Aufarbeitung Schmerz ganz sicher an
vielen Stellen vor allem weil sie unter
den Augen der Öffentlichkeit stattfindet
aber meine Damen und Herren sie ist
notwendig nur so kann es gelingen
verloren gegangenes Vertrauen wieder
herzustellen
meine Damen und Herren
streitet ja niemand ab dass der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk Reformen
braucht vor allem brauchen die Anstalten
eine deutliche Stärkung der
Kontrollgremien in Zeiten in denen sich
private wie öffentliche Unternehmen
strenge Compliance Regeln auserlegt
haben müssen selbstverständlich auch
Führungspersönlichkeiten in
Rundfunkanstalten ihr Handeln
transparent darlegen die
zeitpatriarchalisch handelnder
Intendanten und Intendantinnen ist
vorbei schlimm genug dass man das
erwähnen muss was allerdings nicht und
zwar wirklich nicht auf dem Prüfstand
gehört ist der öffentlich-rechtliche
Rundfunk an sich
der öffentliche Rundfunk hat bei uns
seine Rolle darin politisch und
wirtschaftlich unabhängig und natürlich
ausgewogen demokratische Prozesse
transparent und sichtbar zu machen der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk soll die
freie Meinungsbildung fördern die
kulturelle Vielfalt darstellen und einen
umfassenden Überblick über das regionale
nationale und internationale Geschehen
gewährleisten und
selbstverständlich beziehen sich diese
Anforderungen auf das Gesamtprogramm und
nicht nur auf einzelne Sendungen bzw
Sendungsformate schon gar nicht bezieht
sich dies auf dem Verzicht von
Unterhaltungssendungen auch in Zeiten
der dringend notwendigen Reformen
stärken wir den öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunk und damit meine Damen und
Herren die Pressefreiheit und die Presse
Vielfalt in Deutschland
am Rande bemerkt beides
Pressefreiheit und Pressevielfalt nützt
auch denen die gern über den
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk
herziehen und Ihnen am liebsten
abschaffen würden wir als Koalition
stehen an der Seite des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks ich
danke Ihnen für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
die monacous war das für die
SPD-Fraktion ihr folgt jetzt hier in
dieser aktuellen Stunde der nächste
Redner das ist Matthias Helfrich er
spricht als fraktionsloser Abgeordneter
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin wenn
deutsche Produktion für amateurhaftes
erziehungsfernsehen steht dass in der
Parteizentrale der Grünen hätte gedreht
sein können wenn der Täter im Tatort
stets der 50-Jährige weiße aber nie der
Junge Syrer ist und Reportagen an der
Grenze scharenweise Kinder mit
Kulleraugen statt bärtige Araber zeigen
dann meine Damen und Herren befinden wir
uns in der Parallelgesellschaft von ARD
und ZDF die uns übrigens mehr kostet als
der gesamte Staatshaushalt von Island
das Treiben der ARD klaren Familie wurde
lange von ihnen allen gedeckt der linke
Parteienstaat stand mit eiserner
Entschlossenheit hinter seinem
Propagandaapparat doch die
Familienoberhäupter der sendezentralen
haben es nun etwas mit ihren
astronomischen Gehältern Dienstwagen und
sogar Massagesesseln überreizt
der etablierte Machtblock mit seinen
Rundfunk und parteienzentralen reicht
von den Grünen bis zur Union und alle
brauchen Sie die ARD um ihre bunte
Agenda in die Köpfe der Leute zu hämmern
dass die in ARD steht für Dressur
grundsätzliche Reformideen des Rundfunks
kommen hingegen ausschließlich von der
AFD es gibt aber noch eine weitere
Möglichkeit der Gegenwehr die wir
Mitbürger da oben und die lautet
Schaffung einer medialen kontrakultur da
die etablierten den Rundfunk für ihre
Umerziehung missbrauchen erlaube ich mir
nun ein Werbeblock für Oppositionelle
Medien ganz frei von GEZ-Gebühr Herr
Lindt bestellen Sie Literatur beim
jungen Europa oder antarius-verlag lesen
Sie die Grauzonen oder die Junge
Freiheit abonnieren Sie den heimatkurier
oder Info direkt aus Österreich stöbern
Sie in den Beiträgen von hallo Meinung
und dem Deutschland Kurier jeder Euro
jeder like für alternative Medien ist
eine saftige Ohrfeige für die Bür und
schlesigers vielen Dank
[Applaus]
für die CDU CSU-Fraktion spricht Herr
Kollege Michael Frieser
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin werte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen also wenn das Haushaltsvolumen
in Island zu interessant ist empfehle
ich einen sehr langfristigen aufhalt
dort um sich mit den Fragen mal
auseinanderzusetzen
es fällt einem schon schwer in dieser
Debatte
wirklich das eigentlich aktuelle zu
erkennen und ich bitte mal sich nicht
davon immer ins Boxern jagen zu lassen
dass hier jemand als Feuerwerk der
schlechten Laune dafür aber der
Desinformation ein Thema auf die
Tagesordnung hebt davon sollten wir uns
sage ich mal als Demokraten insoweit
nicht beeindrucken lassen um zum Kern
vorzustoßen der uns schon als Politik
besorgen muss und da geht es erstmal
natürlich um Fehlverhalten geht es um
persönliches Fehlverhalten geht zum
Nepotismus geht zum die Frage der
Bevorzugung von Freunden
Verwandtschaften oder ähnliches etwas
dass man aufklären kann aber eben auch
aufklären muss etwas wo man deutlich
sagen muss was davon sind in der
tatstrukturelle Probleme es reicht nicht
wenn wir sagen wir stehen fest an der
Seite des öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunks Blick in Verfassung sagt das
ist allenfalls verfassungsgemäß aber
nicht mehr und nicht weniger es geht
schon darum dass wir erkennen dass die
Zeiten sich grundlegend verändert haben
und es ist einfach wahr der sogenannte
Content der produziert wird früher mal
streng getrennt öffentlich-rechtlicher
Rundfunk und Fernsehen und Printmedien
hat sich beim Blick auf die jeweiligen
Seiten stark angenähert ist das noch
gerecht die verantwortungsteilung
funktioniert die tatsächlich noch dass
wir sagen können Printmedien haben im
Grunde eigentlich schlechtere
Startvoraussetzungen für Ihre
Meinungsvielfalt das Spannungsverhältnis
Politik und Rundfunk ein übrigens sehr
sehr interessant ist Herr linda hat eine
große Agenda auf gesagt was man alles
machen müssen was man verbessern müssen
allein die Mitgliedschaft und Mitwirkung
der Politik in den Verwaltungsräten und
Rundfunkgeräten war nicht in der Lage
diese Fragen tatsächlich und deshalb
komme ich Michael Frieser für die
cdu/csu-fraktion hat hier das letzte
Wort in dieser aktuellen Stunde und auch
das letzte Wort hier in unserer
Berichterstattung aus dem Deutschen
Bundestag die Aktuelle Stunde ist auch
so gut wie zu Ende und damit auch dieser
Sitzungstage rund 20 Stunden haben wir
in dieser Woche hier aus dem Bundestag
live für sie berichtet also machen sie
sich das ganze Bild bei Phoenix auch in
der kommenden Woche wieder von dieser
Stelle bleiben sie aber auch jetzt
weiter hier im Programm es folgt Maybrit
Illner mit dem Thema der Krieg
eskalierte wie gefährlich ist Putins
schwächer
glaube es wäre schon besser zu sagen die
Politik soll tatsächlich auch personell
auch bei den Rundfunkgeräten und
tatsächlich den verwaltungsreden ein
Stück Abstand gewinnen wir erschließt
sich nicht ganz warum das notwendig ist
ich glaube der Umgang mit Mitteln der
ist natürlich einfach und populistisch
die sogenannte Tat oder rhidis mein Gott
da darf man mal die Frage stellen
reichen nicht 16 Sendeanstalten mit
ihren Tatorten müssen es auch noch das
gesamte europäische Ausland sein nicht
ganz zu Unrecht fragt man sich ob zwei
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk Anstalten
tatsächlich beim bedauernswerten Ableben
der Queen ganztagesberichten müssen
lässt sich das nicht tatsächlich
zusammenlegen und der Teil der zweite
Punkt ist die Frage naja ein Blick in
die Mediatheken macht es natürlich auch
nicht besser eine Konzentration um auch
dem Betrachter dem Gebührenzahler das
ist Arbeitgeber die Möglichkeit zu geben
auch den Content zu finden der
produziert wird wäre mal zumindest ein
Ansatzpunkt und auf Wesen Rücken geht es
hinaus natürlich auf dem Rücken des
Inhaltes die sogenannten festen freien
wir hoffen sehr dass das ein Stück weit
sich ändern kann und ändern wird die am
Ende des Tages den Inhalt liefern die am
Ende des Tages aus all diesen Strukturen
und diesen Finanzierungen dann vor Ort
stehen und die Berichterstattung
erfolgen müssen einen Auftrag erfüllen
müssen der immer schwerer wird nämlich
die Tatsache gleichzeitig zu sagen ich
brauche einen Text ich brauche die
Bilder ich brauche das Filmchen dazu ich
brauche die Überschriften die
Unterüberschriften das wird nicht
leichte und die Bezahlung an dieser
Stelle höchst bedauerlich und deshalb
noch ins Stammbuch wenn wir schon über
Medien reden dann geht es schon auch ein
bisschen um die Deutsche Welle Liebe
Ampel wenn man der Deutschen Welle so
wichtig sie ist wir wissen das alle und
wir sind uns da ein einen großen
Aufgabenkatalog nicht nur aus dem
ampelkoalitionsvertrag gibt dann muss
man ihnen auch die Mittel dazu geben und
sie ihnen nicht verweigern vielen
[Applaus]
also geehrte Frau Präsident empfehlen
vielen Dank sehr geehrte Kolleginnen und
Kollegen sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
da oben auf der Tribüne und unseren
Zuhörern und das gleich zu Beginn
klarzustellen ja auch ich sehe natürlich
einigen Reformbedarf bei den
öffentlich-rechtlichen Sendern und ich
würde auch sagen die Lösungen müssen an
der Struktur ansetzen das ist ja klar
aber was hier in den vergangenen Wochen
teilweise an Dauerfeuer kommt
erschüttert die Grundfeste unseres
Systems und das kann ich als
innenpolitikerin in diesem Land nicht
unkommentiert lassen die
öffentlich-rechtlichen Medien sind eine
tragende Säule unserer Demokratie sie
sind ein Garant von Freiheit und
Vielfalt wer Hand an ihr Fundament
anlegt richtet die Abrissbirne gegen
unseren Rechtsstaat
es waren vor allem die
öffentlich-rechtlichen die in den
vergangenen Jahren ausführlich und in
der Regel sachlich beispielsweise über
die Gefahren des Islamismus in diesem
Land und in der ganzen Welt aufgeklärt
haben heute sind es vor allem diese
Sender die dir rechtspopulistischen und
rechtsextremen Umtriebe beleuchten Fake
News zerlegen und
Verschwörungsideologien aufwecken
zudem geben sie gemäß ihres Auftrags
auch solchen Menschen eine Reichweiten
starke Stimme die lange Zeit gar keine
Stimme hatten sie machen Sorgen von
jenen sichtbar die sonst unsichtbar sind
Menschen mit Behinderungen Menschen die
von Armut betroffen sind Verlierer der
Wiedervereinigung alleinerziehende
Mütter deutsche mit
Zuwanderungsgeschichte geflüchtete
Homosexuelle queere Menschen
und damit sind wir auch schon beides
Pudels Kern es geht um gesellschaftliche
Minderheiten deren Positionen
wahrzunehmen Vorurteile über sie zu
dekonstruieren all das ist zentral für
eine sozialgerechte Gesellschaft
Gabe
[Applaus]
heute wie kein anderes und das ist der
eigentliche Grund warum Politikerinnen
und Politiker der AFD und einige anderen
diesen Hohen Haus diese am liebsten
abschaffen wollen sie wollen weder dass
solche Minderheiten großartig Gehör
finden sehen wir ja jetzt gerade noch
wollen sie Störfeuer haben wenn sie
gegen sie agitieren in ihrer Illusion
von einer Mehrheitsgesellschaft die sie
nicht mal definieren können
in Wahrheit üben sie nämlich permanent
von der mentalkritik und schließen
süffisant übers Ziel hinaus doch wohin
führt doch wohin das führt sie sehen
sehen wir in Polen sieht man an Polen
und natürlich auch in Ungarn
schauen muss wie niemand sonst machen
sich die rechtskonservativen dort die
Medien Untertan besetzen den Chefetage
mit Günstlingen und geben ganz direkt
order was zu berichten ist und gewiss
müssen deren Führungskräfte nicht schon
beim ersten begründeten öffentlichen
Verdacht ihre Funktionen aufgeben
übrigens wie etwa beim NDR
aber liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen auch
wenn man nach Westen guckt sieht man
ähnliche Entwicklung nehmen Sie die
Schweiz schauen Sie nach Frankreich
Marine Pen reibt sich bereits die Hände
im Vorfreude auf einen erhofften
Bedeutungsverlust der
öffentlich-rechtlichen nach Abschaffung
der Rundfunkgebühren blicken sie nach
Großbritannien wo Boris Johnson den alt
er wird der altehrwürdigen BBC an den
Kragen gegangen ist und warum weil es
ein Tor ist nicht passt was sie
berichtet haben liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen es geht uns nichts an welche
Meinung Journalistinnen und Journalisten
vertreten und was sie und über was sie
berichten wollen nicht Sie nicht mich es
herrscht Programm Autonomie in diesem
Land ja
die Öffis sind weder die Presseabteilung
der Bundesregierung noch der Opposition
sie leben vom politischer Unabhängigkeit
nur der freiheitlichen Grundordnung sind
Sie verpflichtet
darf ich sie an den medienstaatsvertrag
erinnern am § 26 finde ich kam viel zu
wenig hier zu reden Auftrag der Rundfunk
Anstalten ist es Zitat die
demokratischen sozialen und kulturellen
Bedürfnisse der Gesellschaft zu erfüllen
sie sollen die internationalen
Verständigung die europäische
Integration und den gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalt in Bund und Ländern fördern
Zitat Ende kein Wunder also dass sie bei
reaktionären backlashs die ersten sind
die Fallen Beispiel Russland Beispiel
Türkei mal sehen wie es nach dem
Wochenende in Italien weitergeht und was
ohne starke starke Öffis passieren kann
können Sie in den USA studieren
Demokrat und Demokraten in diesem Hohen
Haus müssen zusammenstehen und derartige
Entwicklung zu verhindern ohne
vernünftiges öffentlich-rechtliches
Fernsehen und System ziehen dunkle
Wolken auf wir wären nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg nicht da wo wir heute sind und
für tun sie sich alle nicht auch
Deutschland ist nicht immun gegen
Extremismus in diesem Sinne profitieren
wir als Gesellschaft im Ganzen von
diesem System und daher spielt es im
Einzelfall auch keine Rolle ob jemand
das fernsehradio oder Internetangebot
tatsächlich nutzt Die Freiheit die die
öffentlich-rechtliche mit
aufrechterhalten und befördern dient uns
allen selbst Ihnen das sollte sich jeder
vor Augen halten wenn von irgendwo mal
wieder mit billigen Populismus versucht
wird das öffentlich-rechtliche System
zum Einsturz zu nehmen vielen Dank
für die FDP-Fraktion hat Maximilian
Funke Kaiser jetzt das Wort
ja sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk der ist
eine historisch gewachsene und
seinerzeit elementare Institutionen für
Frieden für Freiheit und für Demokratie
das darf und das wurde auch schon das
ein oder andere Mal in dieser Debatte
genannt nicht in Vergessenheit geraten
es geht um Demokratisierung es geht um
Bildung es geht um die Garantie der
Mündigkeit der Menschen unsere Aufgabe
aus der Geschichte zu lernen genauso ist
es unsere Aufgabe eben all jene
Gräueltaten die in der dunkelsten Zeit
unsere Geschichte passiert sind nicht zu
vergessen und dafür steht eben auch der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk
und wenn es andere nun möglicherweise
anders hin und der Meinung sind dass man
diese Kernaufgabe und den damaligen
begründungszweck anders sehen sollen und
dass der falsch ist dann wäre das einmal
mehr doch recht entlarvend ich denke
alle Demokraten in diesem Raum die sind
sich darüber einig dass das jetzt hier
das ÖAR wichtig ist und als Demokraten
sind wir uns auch einig dass nur eine
ausgewogene und ganzheitliche intensive
Berichterstattung diesem Ziel gerecht
werden kann das muss auch ziel einer
jeden Debatte über den ÖR sein und genau
das ist auch der Auftrag des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks
und liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen so
sehr richtig all diese Ziele sind es ist
genauso richtig dass der ÖR mit der Zeit
gehen muss das bedeutet anders als es
manch anderer gerne hätte im Zweifel
nicht die Zerschlagung unter anderem
Ideen es bedeutet zuallererst erstmal
die Notwendigkeit der Anpassung an neue
Realitäten
insbesondere aber in Zeiten der Krise in
Zeiten in denen jeder und jede den
Gürtel enger schnallen muss in Zeiten in
denen die Energieversorgung unseres
Landes infrage gestellt ist in denen
eine Pandemie unsere Gesellschaft massiv
auf die Probe gestellt hat in denen
Europa einen Angriffskrieg mit allen
Konsequenzen erlebt in denen unser
wirtschaftliches Fundament am Bröckeln
ist wo weichen vor eine Neubegründung
unseres Landes für unseren
wirtschaftlichen Erfolg dringend
benötigt werden Generationen nicht vor
einem Scherbenhaufen stehen sollen wegen
verfehlter Politik in einer solchen Zeit
sollen Rundfunkbeiträge tatsächlich
weiter steigen
sollen beitragsgelder wie berichtet aus
dem Fenster geschmissen werden sollen
keine Maßnahmen zur Effizienzsteigerung
getroffen werden wie es jetzt jeder in
diesem Land macht der mittelständische
Betrieb oder das Kleinstgewerbe um die
Ecke liebe Freunde das kann nicht unser
Ernst sein
wie sollen die Menschen in diesem Land
dennoch irgendetwas ernst nehmen wenn
man solche Sachen hört geschweige denn
dann der über Dinge nicht machen muss
die gerade aktuell das gesamte Land tun
muss es ist unsere Aufgabe als Politik
als Staat verantwortungsvoll mit den
Geldern in diesem Land umzugehen für die
Investition in die Zukunft dieses Landes
und auch für die Sicherstellung des
Wohlstands von morgen dass wir die
Gesellschaft stärken dass sie ihren
sozialen Pflichten nachkommen kann das
ist die Kernaufgabe des Staates und
genauso ist es wir für uns als Staat die
Aufgabe des ÖAR mit den Abgaben die wir
in dieses System geben auch vernünftig
zu haushalten
verantwortungsvolles Wirtschaft mit den
Abgaben auf der einen Seite und die
Erfüllung des Auftrages auf der anderen
Seite liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Demokraten
Demokraten wir setzen uns für eine
moderne für einen schlanken
öffentlich-rechtlichen funkfunk an es
geht um Nachrichten es geht um
politische Bildung es geht um
Dokumentation ja es kann auch um Kultur
gehen und aber sorry Kultur das bedeutet
nicht die x- Quizshow und es bedeutet
auch nicht dass Playback Konzert ich
würde mir wünschen weniger Traumschiff
und Helene ich würde mir mehr
Bundestagsdebatten im
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk wünschen
ich würde mir eine objektive
Berichterstattung darüber wünschen mehr
Geld für die Redakteure statt mehr Cash
und Privilegien für die Chefetage den
Beitrag des ÖAR reduzieren also weniger
Abgaben für die Menschen durch
Strukturreformen in der Verwaltung das
hat der Kollege Hacker gerade vorhin
auch gesagt ordentliche Kooperation und
Konzentration auf die Kernaufgaben nicht
erforderliche parallelangebote abstellen
und mal ganz ehrlich wollen wir ein
funktionierendes duales Mediensystem
dann braucht es Ausgewogenheit die
Verhältnismäßigkeit zwischen
rundfunkbeiträgen und den Wettbewerb der
muss gewahrt sein es schlicht nicht
Aufgabe des öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunks in Konkurrenz zu treten mit
privaten Anbietern und abschließend all
das gesagt diese Reformen des öars das
die brauchen wir aber vergessen wir
dabei nicht eines wir reden schon sehr
sehr lange über diese Reformen und ich
möchte an dieser Stelle auch an die
flammende Eröffnungsrede des damaligen
Bundestagspräsidenten Norbert Dammert
erinnern es gab damals sehr viel Applaus
und was ist dabei in der letzten Zeit in
den letzten Jahren passiert die Antwort
wissen wir alle selber und denken wir
noch ein Stück weiter Reformen braucht
unser Land in Gänze herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
der Kollege marco wanderwitz hat jetzt
das Wort für die cdu/csu-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir stehen hier
im Deutschen Bundestag an einem
Freitagnachmittag und sprechen über ein
Thema für das wir kaum
verfassungsrechtliche Zuständigkeit und
Kompetenz haben ich denke mir bei
mancher Landtagsdebatte die man so aus
den deutschen Landtagen sieht warum wird
dort zu viel über Themen diskutiert für
die die Landtage keine
verfassungsrechtliche Kompetenz haben
die Antwort warum wir über ein Thema
diskutieren über das 16 Landtage
berechtigterweise diskutieren ist weil
die AFD der Meinung ist hier diesen
Antrag stellen zu müssen
die AFD ist es auch die sich einreibt in
den
illustrieren Geleitzug von Diktaturen
die Fake News Verbreiten von Querdenkern
die Fake News verbreiten und das tun
eben auch rechtsradikale so wie sie
regelmäßig wir haben ja heute wieder
hier die Beispiele gehört deswegen hat
frau Kollegin Sitte natürlich recht auch
wenn der Spruch nicht von ihnen ist und
auch nicht von mir und gleichwohl will
ich ihn gerne zitieren wenn es den
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk noch
nicht gebe müssten wir Ihnen erfinden
dass sie hier in diesem Haus sitzen ist
allein schon Grund dafür
wir haben eine gut funktionierende duale
deutsche medienordnung die weit besser
funktioniert in den allermeist in den
allermeisten Ländern dieser Erde mit
hoher Qualität mit Pluralität und
Vielfalt und zwar von
öffentlich-rechtlichen und privaten und
ich glaube die hohe Qualität der
privaten hat auch ein wenig damit zu tun
dass die öffentlich-rechtliche bei uns
so eine hohe Qualität hat er ist
staatsfern organisiert er hat den klaren
Auftrag wir haben dazu eine gefestigte
Rechtsprechung das
Bundesverfassungsgerichts
Informationsauftrag Bildungsauftrag
Kulturauftrag auch ein wenig
unterhaltungsauftrag vor allen Dingen
aber redaktionelle Unabhängigkeit und
gremienkontrolle
und deshalb ist völlig klar wenn es
Verfehlungen gibt und die gibt es
ich gehöre aber auch zu denen die wenn
man mal sich ist ganz genau anschaut
natürlich gar nicht anders können als zu
sagen es sind Einzelfälle es ist nicht
ein systemisches Versagen sondern es
sind Menschen die wie in vielen Fällen
in der Gesellschaft leider sich falsch
verhalten und deswegen gilt es vor allen
Dingen die Gremien zu stärken
und genau das macht der neue
ausgehandelte medienstaatsvertrag er
stärkt die Kontrollrechte der Gremien
und er fokussiert ein weiteres Mal den
Auftrag der öffentlich-rechtlichen
und ob ihnen das passt oder nicht die
Mehrheitsgesellschaft in diesem Land
beantwortet die jeden Monat gestellte
Frage der Forschungsgruppe Wahlen ich
zitiere wenn es um die Berichterstattung
in öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehsendern
wie ARD und ZDF geht ist dort ihr
Vertrauen dass dort wahrheitsgemäß
berichtet wird sehr groß groß nicht so
groß oder haben Sie gar kein Vertrauen
zwischen April 2020 und April 2022 stets
mit 68 bis 74 Prozent mit sehr groß oder
groß das in Mehrheiten von zwei Drittel
bis drei Viertel
ich lass einfach all diese
Unverschämtheiten Dummheiten und
Dreistigkeiten mal so stehen sie können
sie ja leider nicht hören die uns
zuschauen sondern maximal im Protokoll
nachlesen das lohnt dann allerdings
manches Mal
mein nächster Satz wäre davon können wir
alle als politischen Parteien und viele
Akteure der Zivilgesellschaft leider oft
nur träumen von solchen
Zustimmungswerten und deswegen will ich
an dieser Stelle vor allen Dingen den
Journalistinnen und Journalisten den
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern und
den in den Gremien engagierten das sind
nämlich alles Ehrenamtler auch einmal
herzlich Dank dafür sagen dass sie
gemeinsam diesen öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunk seit über 70 Jahren in der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland so entwickelt
haben wie wir ihn haben
und deswegen noch ein ganz kleines Fazit
erstens wir brauchen den
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk dringend
er ist konstitutiv für das Gelingen der
Demokratie zweitens natürlich gibt es
allzeit Reformbedarf das Thema Internet
neue Medien ist bereits angesprochen
crossmedialität aber diese Reformen hat
es ja in den letzten Jahren auch gegeben
und wir dürfen natürlich das Kind hier
nicht sprichwörtlich mit dem
badeausschütten sondern müssen mit
Augenmaß an diese Reform herangehen und
als letzter Punkt da glaube ich sind wir
uns hier im Hause alle einig Kollegin
Wagenknecht ist ja heute nicht da wir
werden uns von ihnen von den
Rechtsradikalen in diesem Haus den
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk sicher
nicht kaputt machen lassen
Matthias Mewes spricht für die
SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
also ich hoffe es gilt das für die
anderen für die meisten anderen geht es
auch guten Tag zusammen
18 Euro 36 das kostet uns der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk und zwar
jeden Monat und ich möchte gern darauf
eingehen wofür war das eigentlich
bezahlen und ich möchte dabei drei
Themen in den Mittelpunkt rücken erstens
was bekommen wir denn eigentlich dafür
zweitens was wären die Alternativen und
drittens was muss ich eigentlich ganz
konkret ändern
ja 18 Euro 36 was bekommen wir dafür wir
bekommen dafür erstmal ein mega gutes
Abo hey da ist alles drin von
Unterhaltung über Sport bis
Informationen wir bekommen zum Beispiel
Barbara Schöneberger die uns jedes Jahr
mit dem Eurovision Song Contest die
ganze Vielfalt die Freude und den
Zusammenhalt Europas in die Wohnzimmer
bringt
und
wir bekommen dafür auch Marietta Slomka
die sehr dafür schätze dass Sie unsere
Regierungsmitglieder regelmäßig hart
aber fair in die Mangel nimmt und wir
müssen natürlich auch jede Woche den
dicken welke ertragen der uns allen
zusammen hier zurecht auch mal die
Leviten liest
naja
[Gelächter]
über über diese konkreten Angebote
hinaus sind die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen
aber ein Bollwerk gegen Fake News die
öffentlichen sind es Fundament für gute
Informationen für Verlässlichkeit für
Sachlichkeit in den Medien und damit
sind die öffentlichen für mich und für
uns alle ein wichtiges Fundament für
unsere Freiheit und für unsere
Demokratie
und dieser Wert geht am Ende deutlich
über die Kosten hinaus das was die
öffentlichen liefern kostet 18 Euro 36
hat aber ein deutlich höheren Wert für
uns alle
was sind die Alternativen die
Alternativen sind auf der einen Seite
Medienlandschaften die komplett vom
Kapital kontrolliert werden und die auf
der anderen Seite komplett von
staatenmissbraucht werden um ihre
Gesellschaften zu kontrollieren deshalb
brauchen wir einen anderen Weg wo die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger zwar dafür zahlen
aber am Ende sich die Medien auch danach
richten die Bedürfnisse der Bürgerinnen
und Bürger zu erfüllen nämlich für uns
da zu sein in den USA sehen wir was
passieren kann wenn Kapital wenn
kapitalgetriebene Sender ihre Anstalten
missbrauchen um Kampagnen zu betreiben
in Australien haben wir gesehen was
passiert wenn Imperien genutzt werden um
den Kampf gegen den Klimawandel
aufzuhalten und zu verlangsamen das
wollen wir nicht bei uns und wir wollen
auch nicht das andere Extrem wo in
Staaten die Russland und China
Regierungen
medienmissbrauchen um Menschen zu
kontrollieren um ihnen Meinungen
einzubläuen wenn sie am Ende von einem
freiheitlichen Leben abzuhalten das
wollen wir nicht wir brauchen den Weg wo
Bürgerinnen und Bürger ihre ihren
öffentlichen Rundfunk finanzieren und am
Ende damit auch ein ganz klaren Auftrag
geben nämlich für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger zu arbeiten
im dritten Punkt reden wir darüber was
ich ändern muss ja wir haben ein Skandal
und der muss aufgearbeitet werden es
müssen Konsequenzen gezogen werden und
wir müssen sicherstellen dass das nicht
noch mal passiert und daran wird konkret
schon was getan die Rundfunkkommission
hat gerade gestern getagt und hat ganz
konkrete Beschlüsse gefasst wo es darum
geht bessere Kontrollmechanismen
einzuführen wo es darum geht dass auch
Sparsamkeit einen stärkeren Fokus
bekommt und wo es darum geht dass
Intendantinnen und Intendanten stärker
dafür Rechenschaft ablegen müssen was in
ihren Anstalten passiert das ist gut und
richtig denn auf der einen Seite haben
wir Leute die die rumbrüllen für die
Kameras und auf der anderen Seite haben
wir Menschen die für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger arbeiten und konkrete
Verbesserungen einführen das zweite ist
unser Weg und dass der richtige der
einzige der Ergebnisse bringt
18 Euro 36
das sind die Kosten für den
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk im Monat
das ist das was jeder bezahlen muss aber
das was es was er für uns wert ist ist
am Ende unbezahlbar vielen Dank fürs
zuhören und ein schönes Wochenende
ich schließe die Aussprache wir sind am
Ende unserer heutigen Tagesordnung ich
berufe ein die nächste Sitzung des
Deutschen Bundestages auf Mittwoch den
28 September um 13 Uhr bis dahin
genießen Sie die sitzungsfreie Zeit die
Arbeit den Sonntag und vor allem die
gewonnenen Einsichten die Sitzung ist
geschlossen